Florida is facing a fuel crisis in the
wake of Emma gasps gasps shortages
rather there along with block roads and
traffic delays are making the drive home
very difficult for many evacuees Adriana
Diaz is in Orlando where many gas
stations are running out of fuel Adriana
good morning good morning that's right
many stations across the state still
don't have gas like this Chevron they
still have the plastic wrap around the
pump that was protection to make sure
that the nozzle didn't go flying off
during the storm now the situation is
spotty this station has no gas but the
station across does have gas and what
happened was that the massive
evacuations ahead of the storm sent
people rushing to gas stations to fill
up their tanks fill up their gas cans
and now that people tens of thousands of
them are returning home they're going to
stations that have no gas that's
creating long lines at the stations that
do have gas now part of the problem is
that some seaports here in Florida are
still closed so there is less new fuel
coming into the state according to the
tracking site Gas Buddy more than 40% of
stations here in Orlando have no gas
more than 65% of stations in Gainesville
have no gas and more than 60% of
stations in Miami and Fort Lauderdale
now there is some good news and all of
this the port of Florida is expected to
reopen this afternoon there are
currently vessels waiting offshore with
gas waiting to make their deliveries
once the port does reopen Norah all
right thank you so much Adriana